una semana desde el terremoto unas
semanas sin techo sin agua y sin comida
para los que en la localidad de
marcelino sobrevivieron a la catástrofe
natural que causó más de 2.000 muertes
el pasado sábado los habitantes de esta
zona rural a 25 kilómetros de los cayos
denuncian que no ha llegado ninguna
ayuda y que sienten el olor de la
descomposición entre las ruinas
no hemos recibido nada aquí no hemos
recibido ni comida ni agua necesitamos
carpas para dormir afuera no tenemos
quiero que las autoridades nos ayuden
con carpas y alimentos tenemos niños
pequeños que no tienen nada que comer
mientras en la periferia de los cayos la
ayuda del programa mundial de alimentos
se empezó a llegar
esta comida es muy importante para mí la
llevaré a casa será una oportunidad para
compartirla con mis vecinos que la
necesitan los que no están en las listas
de ayuda más veo como cada más de uno
cada vive
el viernes una delegación de naciones
unidas- se desplazó hasta la zona más
afectada frente a la devastación los
representantes de la onu alabaron la
resiliencia del pueblo haitiano ante el
espiral de crisis en el que está asumido
el país una oportunidad opinaron para
reforzar la unidad nacional
el gobierno y la sociedad civil están
definiendo cómo quieren ser ayudados y
acompañados para recuperarse de mucha
mejor manera que en el pasado
o aprender las lecciones de la mala
gestión de la crisis desatada por el
terremoto de 2010 es la promesa
reiterada por el primer ministro ariel
en río
me he comprometido a ponerlo todo en
marcha para volver a encarrilar mi país
en una democracia funcional y organizar
lo antes posible elecciones libres y
transparentes
unas elecciones convocadas por el
presidente joven el mois antes de ser
asesinado el pasado 7 de julio y que
tras el magnicidio quedaron en el aire